les formulaires aux il est nécessaire
pour l'obtention du laissez-passer bonne
fête astérix 60 à tout petit luc vidal
est tombé dans la potion magique de
panoramix et but par astérix
voici ici ma petite collection
ça me rappelle mon enfance et ça l'a
fait sohou des portes ça reviens te
chercher
par toutatis ce passionné a bien sûr
tous les albums mais il collectionne
aussi des figurines des dessins des
verts il entretient même une
correspondance avec albert uderzo le
dessinateur originales d'astérix et
chaque année il lui envoie des produits
de l'érable à 97 je les rencontre et
c'est long et drogue
j'essaie de trouver cia l'a toujours
traditionnelle canne de sirop
mais j'essaie de trouver des produits
dérivés du sud qui revient bientôt aux
jo et il recule pour le dîner
publié pour la première fois dans le
magazine français pilotes en octobre
1959 les aventures d'astérix et obélix
ont connu un tel succès qu'elles ont été
rapidement traduite bien sûr en anglais
mais aussi en arabe en hébreu en turc et
en italien
au total il s'est vendu en 60 ans 380
millions d'exemplaires des albums il ya
aussi eu des dessins animés cultes et
des films mémorables dont mission
cléopâtre astérix et lui et obélix fait
le pli celle ses idées fixes restent rx
et c'est un parc d'attraction en france
le parc astérix
des répliques qui reste aussi t'es tombé
dedans tu es tombé dedans quand tu étais
petit quand on peut l'entendre encore
dans les familles parce que ça a dépassé
le simple le simple monde de la bande
dessinée
le québec a aussi été conquis par
astérix et ses amis gaulois
il ya eu des expositions dont celle au
musée des beaux-arts de montréal en 1997
et comme on peut le lire dans l'ouvragé
de tristan demers le lien est profond
astérix on s'identifie parce qu'on est
entouré 360 millions d'anglophones
alors c'est sûr qu'on ya une parenté là
bas le village gaulois qui résiste c'est
un peu ça le village francophone qui
résiste
astérix est d'ailleurs de retour dans un
38e album et un nouveau film est en
préparation
cette fois ci le petit guerrier se
rendra en chine
ici oui fait déprimer fera du canada
n'ont rien